um hey yo it's your boy Jamaal aka DJ
salad we got some thin love right here
the homey Grover what's happening what's
up yeah hey they don't want you to be a
legend hey what don't want you to be a
legend
well first off marques coach Bundy it's
that reality check your jump shot is
minor-key alert more fan love here's my
boy milk what's up y'all just want to
give shout to my thigh bull dark isha
and a t-ball Laden who days I'm with
your pasty ass 24/7 11 and I never heard
it in particular damn Jamal snappers for
the boobs not the nose and yo heavyset
hair keep hogging the whole screen hey
they don't want you to be mean email
model material so we go beef meat email
model material oh I like
[Music]